If you've watched my review of Disney's new
live-action Beauty and the Beast movie, you'll
know how much I enjoyed it.
But now I want to see how much of a super-fan
you are of the original animated movie, which,
by the way, was the first animated feature
ever to be nominated for a Best Picture Oscar.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video, I'm going to reveal a wealth
of fascinating facts about Disney's classic
animation, Beauty and the Beast, so be my
guest and put your Disney knowledge to the
test!
When it came to creating the book-loving Belle,
the filmmakers took their cues from the golden
age of Hollywood.
For example, Belle's blue-and-white outfit
channels actress Judy Garland's look in the
Wizard of Oz, as well as emphasising visually
just how different Belle is from the people
in her town as she's the only character who
wears blue in the opening sequence.
But Belle's costume isn't the only thing that
links her to Judy Garland.
In fact, one of the reasons that Paige O'Hara
was selected to bring Belle to life was that
her voice and manner were reminiscent of the
quality and warmth of Garland's voice.
Other Hollywood icons also left their mark
on the character of Belle.
For instance, screenwriter Linda Woolverton
took cues from actress Katharine Hepburn,
especially her performance as the spirited
and literature-loving Jo March in the 1930s
film Little Women.
And that was just the beginning of screen
legend Hepburn's influence on the animated
classic.
Indeed, Belle's interaction with the Beast,
for example, when she tends his wounds, was
partly inspired by the on-screen verbal sparring
between Hepburn and Spencer Tracy in the many
movies they made together.
As we all know from his boastful song, no
one does anything quite like Gaston.
Yet, despite Gaston's insistence on his uniqueness,
the filmmakers did actually draw inspiration
from a number of places when they created
his character.
First of all, they channelled the pompous
Roman soldier, Miles Gloriosus, from Stephen
Sondheim's musical, A Funny Thing Happened
on the Way to the Forum, which was made into
a film in 1966, and was a particular favourite
of Beauty and the Beast producer Don Hahn
and lyricist Howard Ashman.
And when she was writing the big-headed Gaston,
screenwriter Linda Woolverton also had in
mind some of her ex-boyfriends.
Looks-wise, the animators modelled Gaston
after good looking soap opera stars and added
a dash of Superman, as the idea was to make
him incredibly handsome and, basically the
polar opposite of the Beast in both personality
and appearance.
Speaking of the Beast, animator Glen Keane,
who designed that character, was banned from
meeting actor Robby Benson who voiced the
Beast until after the movie was finished,
which was very unusual because, on other animated
movies, Keane normally spent time with the
actors during their recording sessions.
However, Jeffrey Katzenberg, who was Disney's
studio chief at the time, specifically didn't
want Keane to be influenced by Benson's looks,
personality, or mannerisms in how he animated
the Beast.
As for the design of the Beast, that was based
on a variety of animals that Keane observed
and sketched at London Zoo in Regent's Park,
including wolves, gorillas, and mandrills,
whose eyes he felt were very human and conveyed
real intelligence.
Keane also bought a buffalo head from a taxidermist.
And in the end, the features of the Beast
combine a lion's mane, a buffalo's head, a
gorilla's brow, human eyes, a cow's ears,
a bear's body, and a wolf's tail and legs.
When making animated movies, more often than
not, actors record their roles separately,
but for Beauty and the Beast, Paige O'Hara
persuaded Disney's powers that be to let her
and Robby Benson record Belle and Beast's
lines together, which they found really helped
them get the dynamic right between their characters
as it developed over the course of the story.
By the way, Benson prepared for his Beauty
and the Beast recording sessions by doing
the kind of vocal warm-ups he used to get
ready when he performed in Broadway shows.
It's almost hard to imagine now that we know
the movie so well, but several of the film's
characters started out with different names.
In earlier versions of the story, Mrs Potts
was actually called Mrs Chamomile.
The filmmakers originally named her 'Chamomile'
after the soothing herbal tea, but decided
to change it when it occurred to them it may
be difficult to pronounce, especially for
young children.
As for Jerry Orbach's character Lumiere, he
was initially going to be named Chandal, short
for the word chandelier, but again, the filmmakers
thought the name would be too tough to say,
so instead they went with the name we know
today, which was inspired by early cinema
pioneers the Lumiere Brothers.
Mrs Potts may sound wonderfully soothing singing
about the 'tale as old as time' in the movie's
title track, however, what happened to actress
Angela Lansbury right before she recorded
the song was anything but!
Lansbury was on her way to record the tune
with the New York Philharmonic when the plane
she was on was forced to make an emergency
landing in Las Vegas due to a bomb scare!
Although producer Don Hahn suggested she rest
up overnight in Vegas, undeterred, Lansbury
caught another flight and continued on her
journey to New York that same day, going straight
into her recording session with the Philharmonic,
where she nailed the song in just one take,
which is exactly what we hear in the film!
Originally, Mrs Potts' son Chip was only supposed
to say a single sentence in the whole movie,
and that line was: 'Momma, there's a girl
in the castle'.
The rest of the scenes where Chip appears
in the film as it stands today were actually
meant to feature a Music Box which, instead
of speaking, made little chiming noises.
However, the filmmakers decided they wanted
to add a child's perspective to the movie
in order to make it easier for kids to relate
to the story, and because they liked child
actor Bradley Michael Pierce's voice as Chip,
they kept increasing his dialogue.
One of the most enchanting parts of Beauty
and the Beast is its songs, so it's incredible
to think that composer Alan Menken and lyricist
Howard Ashman ever doubted their brilliance
for even a second!
In fact, they were so uncertain whether the
filmmakers would like the opening song they'd
written for Belle that they flew from Upstate
New York, where they wrote the soundtrack,
all the way to Los Angeles to play it in person
for the filmmaking team.
Basically, Menken and Ashman were worried
the filmmakers would think they'd gone mad
because they covered so many details in the
space of just a few minutes in that first
song; so, for example, we meet Belle, Gaston
and LeFou, and we find out what kind of people
they are, and we learn all about Belle's town
and its inhabitants and how they're so different
from her.
But Menken and Ashman shouldn't have worried
as the Beauty and the Beast crew loved the
song and the entertaining way it presented
so much information and set up many of the
film's main characters.
And, in fact, the song "Belle" actually ended
up being one of a small number of tracks that
didn't get changed or rearranged over the
course of the movie's development.
So, how big a fan are you of Beauty and the
Beast & how many of those facts did you know?
And which is your favourite character and
song in the movie?
Let me know in the comments below.
I've got lots more Beauty And The Beast videos
on the way, including some very cool secrets
about the making of the new movie, so do subscribe
and turn on your notifications for Flicks
And The City to make sure you don't miss any
of my new videos!
And if you enjoyed this, I really appreciate
you giving it a thumbs-up and sharing it and
why not tap or click here to check out some
more videos you might like on my channel?!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers.